the World Health Organization says most
people with mild cases of kovat 19
should be okay again within two weeks
but thousands of patients are
experiencing serious physical and mental
symptoms months after they've apparently
recovered from the disease they can
include fever vision problems burning
skin exhaustion hair loss brain fog and
shortness of breath it's unclear how
common this is our doctor Tara Narula
spoke with several people sometimes
called long haulers the car ride home
was amazing I you know the the skies
never seemed so bluer the covent 19
survivor ernesto castro
says the day he left the hospital was
one of the best days of his life did you
feel you had survived you'd beaten this
or were you still having some issues at
that point being in the hospital first
along being in the isolation it was
really hard I knew that my muscles
atrophied I could hardly walk me I feel
like I got a new opportunity late March
Castro was in the hospital for ten days
with severe Cova 19 symptoms he was put
on a ventilator in a medically induced
coma months later it's clear his battle
with the disease is not over I'm still
still feel tired I still have no stamina
it doesn't look like much but to me it's
kind of like Mount Everest I have to do
every day
Candice McKinney was hospitalized for
kovin 19:00 for four days in April but
she never went to the ICU in May she
tested negative but hasn't fully
recovered either two or three times in
order to comprehend what I'm reading
McKinney's experienced some stranger
side-effects - including loss of hair
and the sensation of burning skin my
skin studies show kovat 19 patients may
experience lingering symptoms from lung
kidney heart
brain and nervous system damage caused
by the disease they left the hospital
because they were well enough to get out
of hospital doesn't mean that they're
healthy dr. Martha sir Raman leads a
post discharge clinic for kovat 19
patients at SUNY Downstate sparklin
Hospital the clinic taps in two
different specialists to help patients
recover and learn more about the disease
is called Eden involves the brain the
nervous system the skin the kidneys the
heart the lungs the GI tract sounds like
the message you're saying is just
because you've survived covin you are
not out of the woods there may be
long-term lingering effects on multiple
different organ systems yes I mean
absolutely patients may have lingering
side effects that is not apparent yet
but being a few months few years from
now I got sick March 15th of this year
and I've just never gotten better Amy
Watson tested positive for the corona
virus with mild to moderate symptoms in
April she's tested negative three times
since but she's still in pain has
shortness of breath and memory loss got
a fever the entire time she started a
Facebook support group with more than
6,000 members for long-haul kovat 19
fighters like herself we don't want to
be second-guessed we want to be believed
and we want doctors just tell us hey I
don't know the answers but I'm gonna
help you find them anyway we're
survivors you will get stronger we will
beat this hopefully in the years to come
we'll just look at this as a bump on the
road and we'll give you back to our
normal selves or even better and dr.
taryn Narula joins us now Tara good
morning what's the thing that surprises
me the most in these lingering effects
here is is what we call brain fog or the
confusion or the memory loss what what
are what are doctors learning about
about the mental the lingering mental
effects of this well I'm really glad you
asked about that Anthony because many of
these patients are going to face a
second battle and that battle has to do
with mental health conditions experts
have told us they expect to see an
uptick in depression anxiety and in
particular PTSD
we know that impatient
in general who come out of the ICU they
can be at risk for some of these
conditions but now imagine these are
patients who've been seeing doctors in
full PPE spacesuits without that
connection
they've been socially isolated from
their family and they're coming back
into a world that's completely different
socially and economically and so even
you know the patient that we interviewed
ernesto castro and the piece he said I
think I'll recover physically I don't
think I'll ever recover mentally he was
diagnosed with PTSD and gave us some
examples about waking up with nightmares
in a cold sweat his two-year-old
daughter kind of playfully jumping on
his chest while he was sleeping and he
pushed her off feeling that sensation of
being suffocated again like that when
they were putting the mask on him and he
was being intubated so really important
for families to know that when their
family members come home they may be at
risk for this for doctors to be
screening and very important for
patients to know if they experienced any
of this - please speak up and speak to
their provider and get help all right
dr. tara Narula thank you so much